ich habe mich in absprache mit kathrin
antoni hier noch kurz reingedrängt um
angesichts des heutigen tages noch ein
paar dinge nochmal klarzustellen der
erste punkt ist dass annalena baerbock
und ich in großer gemeinsamkeit und
großer geschlossenheit und großer stärke
die koalitions unseren jungs gespräche
gemeinsam führen werden und gemeinsam
vorbereiten das betrifft die personelle
wie auch die innerliche vorbereitung
voll umfassend das zweite ist und sie
werden es bei dem abend am sonntag noch
in erinnerung haben dass die partei
120 prozentige geschlossenheit hinter
annalena baerbock den bundesvorstand
aber vor allem auch ihr als person steht
das dritte ist dass wir gestern auf der
bundespressekonferenz auf nachfrage
gesagt haben dass wir zwischen uns alle
fragen geklärt haben das ist aber auch
völlig klar ist dass diese fragen jetzt
nicht diskutiert werden sollen dass es
sich geradezu nicht gezielt ins
personalspekulationen einzusteigen bevor
wir überhaupt sondierungsgespräche
aufgenommen haben oder eine regierung
haben die frage bei vizekanzler wird ist
völlig irrelevant wir haben nicht nur
einen kanzler an der stelle der vierte
punkt ist das selbstverständlich am ende
eines solchen prozesses über inhalte und
personal das gesamte tableau die partei
über ein parteitag oder über eine
mitgliederbefragung entscheiden wird und
der letzte punkt hier nicht gerne sagen
möchte ist das an alena gerber von ich
die letzten jahre die partei so
aufgebaut und versucht haben so zu
führen dass wir einen geist der
anerkennung des respekts der solidarität
miteinander haben und das ist auch der
geist den ich in den nächsten wochen und
monaten von uns allen erwarte und nichts
anderes soweit vielen dank ich gehe
wieder meine wege